all right for the 70 percent of college
graduates who are now entering the
workforce with student debt listen up
experts say it's time to get organized
they recommend you list out each loan
detailing interest rates monthly
payments due and even contact
information focus on paying off the
highest interest loans first then work
your way down to the lower interest ones
try and set up automatic payments as
well directly to the lender and that'll
help avoid penalties or late fees
and if you're headed off to college it's
about to get even more expensive for the
upcoming and current students we spoke
with one expert about what to do to
shore up your financial plans ahead of
the fall semester
it's a tough time to be a college
student they're spending more money on
gas to get to and from
college to get to and from their job
they're spending money on food if your
college bound student is going away to
college then they're also dealing with
more expensive airfare they may not be
able to come home to visit as often a
situation which can affect them
emotionally as well as financially
because besides inflation across the
board whatever money anyone has saved
for college isn't worth as much as it
was just a few months ago due to stock
market losses families that thought they
had enough to cover and now they're
finding they don't
401ks have gone down in value stocks and
other investments and so families that
may have been thinking they were going
to either borrow from those funds or
pull or just pull money out
now that money is not going to go as far
so it's really affected students and
their families much more than maybe the
average person has considered now is the
time for college students to work get as
many hours as possible at a full-time
job even get a side hustle consider
driving for uber or lyft grocery
delivery you can choose your hours and
here's something else to put on your
radar even though january through march
is the busiest time to apply for
scholarships they are available right
now scholarship providers offer
scholarships year-round so if you think
you've missed the boat you didn't you
can get in that boat and start applying
for scholarships right now and hopefully
make some money through scholarships
before your tuition bill is due in
august
there are currently right now eight
hundred thousand dollars worth of
national scholarships on the scholarship
owl platform